car fans and lovers of free stuff
rejoice sony is going to release the
free PS Plus version of drive club as
quickly as possible I'm cam Robinson and
this internet video is a Jesus news
update questions were raised yesterday
over whether or not PlayStation Plus
subscribers were ever going to see the
free edition of drive club as promised
by Sony all the way back in 2013 we even
did a video about it yesterday look how
young I look anyway the news is we're
getting it and here's the quote we
received from Sony this morning although
currently we do not have an update
regarding the timing for the launch of
the PS Plus addition we are continually
working on improving the server capacity
to enable us to launch the PS bus
edition as quickly as possible what they
are referring to there are the massive
server issues they faced when the full
version of driveclub launched in october
last year after a host of setbacks and
delays the PS Plus version smaller in
scale and creat subscribers was due to
launch after the main game but given
these previous troubles Sony were
reluctant to push head until the game
was ready when asked if gamers were ever
gonna see the free version head of
PlayStation Europe Jim Ryan had said I
can't say anything at this stage two
British paper at the Metro however
today's statement quashes the concerns
of if now it's only a matter of when
which is good news for subscribers of
PlayStation Plus so how do you feel
after this whole debacle as your trust
and Sony being renewed and what other
clubs you like let me know in the
comments down below and for all your
other gaming news just come on back to
gamespot com